[Applaudissements]
s'ils voient ces actes politiques
progresse très bien la preuve qu'on
attendait c'est un peu le temps aux
émissions et qu'elles sont bien faites
et bien ça peut prendre ça s'arrête a
coulé mais je sais mais c'est dommage et
à france télévisions il ya une règle les
émissions saisonnières marque rappelle
l'émission même d'oloron l'émission pour
12 elle commence à monter l'ont arrêté
voilà on a commencé à monter sa red bull
dit que conçoit à oui bonsoir oui
bonsoir
franck gastambide
[Applaudissements]
j'allais au studio d'à côté excuse moi
tu es venu en chiens de traîneau alors
je viens dire je la violer je serai avec
vous lundi qu'elle adore et on racontera
l'année bras contrat lundi
un truc qu'on n'a jamais raconté à la
télé tous les deux ah ouais ouais
le truc que tu m'as fait ouais non j'ai
toujours raconté on va raconter ce à
quoi je vois là et bien là diola un
contrat jusqu'au chalet de fonds engage
soir il est un de mes meilleurs amis
voilà je voulais vous le dire mais c'est
vrai il le sait et c'est beau
de la dore merci faire thébaux et marque
la doudoune à